hey everyone welcome back to day number
13 of css3 in 30 days today we're gonna
be building a CSS sticky footer now what
is a sticky footer well a sticky footer
is a footer on your web page that sticks
to the bottom of your viewport
regardless of the content size within
the page so for example if you have a
page layout and you only have one
sentence and then you have your footer
let's call it a colored footer it's not
going to stay at the bottom of the
viewport of your browser that's because
it collapses up into the end of the
content so your footer is actually a
quarter of the way down the page and you
got all this white space below it it
looks pretty bad now the what
now a sticky footer makes that footer
actually go to the bottom of the browser
viewport even if the content is way up
here so let me show you what that looks
like over here I have in the number 13
sticky footer project files go ahead and
download that there's a number of
different files in this one it's a
little bit different than what we have
normally been doing I'll show you what
that looks like here so we have index
dot HTML final that HTML student dot
HTML and we also have final and sandbox
dot CSS now what why do I have that the
index dot HTML page is the info page
it's just instructions on what you're
going to be building and why you're
gonna be building it and then a couple
of buttons that allow you to go to the
student version and the final version so
the info page is just your instructions
and then our access to these buttons so
if I go to the student version this is
the sandbox the student version with the
sticky footer down here that you need to
make sticky now this is an example of a
non sticky footer the content of this
page here as you can see it is pretty
short and the bottom of the viewport is
way down here and this footer is there
so it's not actually it doesn't actually
look like a footer it's just another
element below this content now we want
to make this footer stick to the bottom
of the viewport like the final version
right here now if I were to resize this
browser window that footer follows along
as you can see there follows where I
dragged and then it stops
at this here and then there's a scroll
so that is a sticky footer and then the
student version you could see is non
sticky so it's actually quite easy to
make this it involves very minimal
markup and just some CSS trickery so
let's go ahead jump into our breyer code
editor here and let's get started
so you don't really need to concern
yourself with index.html it doesn't
really matter so it is final dot HTML if
you want to see the final version you
can see here if I scroll down we have a
few things that you need to note there's
a div here that wraps everything in with
the class called page content now below
that page content it's not within it is
footer and that contains a div as well
all of these elements are important now
if I go to your student dot HTML it's
the same markup we got page content and
then outside of that we have a footer
with a div inside of it now if we go to
our sandbox that CSS let's get started
with our styling of this sticky footer
the first thing that you need to always
do is start off with the HTML and body
select the two of those we're going to
give it a height of 100% and a margin of
zero so we want to clean that up make
sure that the HTML and body have a
height of 100 percent of the viewport
and a margin of zero so it doesn't mess
with our calculations now we're going to
select that page content class that we
saw right here
and in there we're gonna say minimum
height or min height rather of 100% that
forces it to have a minimum height of
100% rather than the height of whatever
is contained so minimum height 100% of
the viewport or its parent which is HTML
and body now we're gonna come back to
page content and give it some negative
margin but first I want to move forward
so that it makes sense why we're giving
it negative margin so let's go down to
page content after and we're gonna say
content it's going to be an empty string
because you know when you have an after
virtual element you need to give it
content so that it actually appears and
display block now we're gonna do is
below that we're gonna select the footer
and page content after now what we're
doing here is we're selecting the footer
itself and the after element the after
virtual element of the page content and
all we're doing is giving it a height of
let's say 120 pixels now you need a
fixed height for the footer it could be
any height that you want if it's only 30
pixels or if it's 500 pixels it's up to
you but you need to know the height
that's the catch with the sticky footer
the reason why is if I were to go and
view this in the browser you can see now
that the footer is actually below the
viewport so if I scroll down there's 120
pixel footer below so all I need to do
here is in the page content element
which is everything within here is bring
that footer up the height of its
container so the height of the footer is
120 pixels so if we go back to page
content and I'm just gonna have a
comment here that says
margin-bottom negative 120 pixels save
that head over to your browser check out
the student version and there's the
sticky footer at the bottom I can't
scroll up and down it's just there and
if I were to bring the viewport smaller
it's a perfect sticky footer if I
brought it all the way up so it bumps up
at the bottom of this content it's going
to stop with the margin that is already
declared there and I could scroll down
so if this content grows this sticky
footer stays where it is until it bumps
up against it and it will push it
further down but it is always stuck to
the bottom of the viewport that is it
for a sticky footer it's very simple
quick overview in the markup we have
page content that div and then outside
of that div we have a footer and then a
dip with in that footer for any content
you have so essentially the mark-up
looks like this you have a div with the
class let's call it page content and
then you have a footer all you're doing
in the CSS is giving the HTML in the
body a height of 100% the page content
itself needs to be minimum height of
100% and the page content after virtual
element needs to be display:block the
footer and the page content after pseudo
element or virtual element is 120 pixels
in this case it could be any height you
want and then the page content needs a
negative bottom margin of the same
height as the footer and then you can
see here that that is all the markup you
need and it should work just fine over
here in your browser that's it for the
sticky footer go ahead and use that in
your own websites I use it for my
websites when I have a footer a client
website or a project website if I have a
footer that I need stuck to the bottom I
will go ahead and create a sticky footer
it takes no time out of your day
to implement hopefully this way valuable
to you see you tomorrow and day 14
[Music]